FROM THE LESSONS NOW SO WE DON’T
HAVE TO SHUT THE COUNTRY DOWN.
GREAT SHOW.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT, BUCKLE UP, WE HAVE A
TON OF BREAKING NEWS TO COVER
INCLUDING SHOCKING NEW VIDEO
FROM NEW YORK CITY WHERE AGAIN,
VIOLENCE TONIGHT IS ERUPTING AND
THE POLICE BUDGET, GET THIS, IS
GETTING SLASHED BY A WHOPPING
$1 BILLION.
THAT IS NOT GOOD NEWS FOR
NEW YORK CITY.
ONE ELDERLY WOMAN WAS EVEN
VIOLENTLY ASSAULTED IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT IN SEATTLE, LOOK AT
THESE IMAGES FROM THE DAILY
MAIL.
OUR VERY OWN DAN SPRINGER AND
HIS CREW, THEY WERE ASSAULTED,
HARASSED, STOCKED, BY THE SUMMER
OF LOVE ZONE PROTESTERS IN THE
SHOP, CHAZ ZONE.
HE WILL TELL US HERE FIRST IN AN
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW AND REPORT
COMING UP, WE WILL ALSO HEAR
FROM ERIC TRUMP TONIGHT,
SENATOR GRAHAM TONIGHT,
MARK CUBAN TONIGHT ON THE
MOUNT RUSHMORE EVENT COMING THIS
WEEKEND.
FIRST, WE HAVE MAJOR NEWS
DEVELOPMENTS TO REPORT.
FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME IN 89
DAYS, HE CAME OUT OF THE BUNKER,
HE CAME OUT OF THE BASEMENT.
THE WEEK, THE EVER-CONFUSED
JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY EMERGED AND
ANSWERED A FEW, WELL, AS MY
FRIENDS ON RADIO TODAY, LOLLIPOP
INTERVIEWS FROM THE MEDIA MOB
AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE IT WAS
PRETTY HARD TO WATCH, THE
DIGRESSIONS, THE STAMMERING, THE
CONFUSION ALL ON DISPLAY AND YOU
CAN JUST FEEL THE TENSION, HE’S
HANGING BY A THREAD THE ENTIRE
TIME.
IF YOU’RE ON HIS STAFF, PLEASE,
PLEASE, JUST ANOTHER MINUTE OR
TWO AND WE WILL PULL YOU OFF THE
STAGE.
YOU CAN TELL HE WAS TRYING SO
HARD BUT THE STRUGGLE IS REAL,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT,
CRITICAL, CRITICAL FOR THE
DELIVERY OF SUPPLIES THAT WERE
BASICALLY NEEDED.
>> CAN YOU TELL US WHAT YOU
WOULD DO TO PUTIN?
IF IT’S TRUE AND IN GENERAL FOR
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE PAST?
>> I CAN BUT I WILL NOT, BUT I
WILL TELL HIM.
WHERE’S THE WILMINGTON,
DELAWARE STATE NEWS?
DELAWARE NEWSROOM I SHOULD SAY,
THAT’S MY HOMETOWN.
IT’S FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
THAN PULLING DOWN A STATUE OR
GOING TO THE LINCOLN MEMORIAL TO
TRY TO, YOU KNOW, NOT
LINCOLN MEMORIAL.
THAT’S A BAD EXAMPLE.
THE JEFFERSON MEMORIAL.
>> Sean: IT TOOK TO THE END OF
THE PRESS OR WHEN YES, FOX NEWS’
OWN DOUG McKELWAY ASKED A
TOUGH BUT IMPORTANT QUESTION AND
BIDEN FIRST REFERRED, THIS WAS
VERY WEIRD.
TO THE DOG AS A DOG FACE, OUT OF
NOWHERE AND THEN GAVE THIS
INCREDIBLY STRANGE ANSWER.
>> LAST QUESTION REALLY QUICK,
SOME OF SPECULATED --
>> YOU ARE A LYING DOG FACE.
>> I DON’T HAVE WORD
RECOLLECTION I USED TO HAVE, I
FORGOT MY TRAIN OF THOUGHT FROM
TIME TO TIME.
I DOI HAVE YOU BEEN TESTED FOR S
DEGREE OF COGNITIVE DECLINE?
>> ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS WATCH
ME AND I CAN HARDLY WAIT TO
COMPARE MY COGNITIVE CAPABILITY
TO THE COGNITIVE CAPABILITY OF
THE MAN I’M RUNNING AGAINST.
>> Sean: OKAY, LET ME GET THIS
STRAIGHT.
HE’S CONSTANTLY BEING TESTED FOR
COGNITIVE ABILITIES?
WHY IS JOE BIDEN GETTING
CONSTANTLY TESTED FOR A
COGNITIVE DECLINE?
AFTER HEARING THAT I’M WONDERING
IF MAYBE ALL AMERICANS NEED
COGNITIVE TESTING REGULARLY.
THAT CONCERNS ME, DOES THAT
CONCERN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
ARE THEY GOING TO ASK THE
EVER-FORGETFUL, WEAK JOE BIDEN
WHY HE’S BEING CONSTANTLY TESTED
FOR COGNITIVE DECLINE?
BECAUSE ASIDE FROM THAT ONE
QUESTION FROM FOX NEWS, BIDEN
WAS GIVEN, AS LEO WAS SAYING ALL
DAY, THE LOLLIPOP QUESTION
TREATMENT FOR MEMBERS OF THE
MOB.
ALMOST AS IF THEY WERE TRYING TO
PROTECT THEM AS THEY HAVE 489
STRAIGHT DAYS.
MANY OF THE QUESTIONS
SURROUNDING MASK-WEARING AND
WHETHER OR NOT HE HAD BEEN
TESTED FOR COVID-19.
OF COURSE, EVERYONE THAT IS
AROUND HIM AND HE ADMITTED ALL
THIS TODAY, INCLUDING ALL OF HIS
HANDLERS, SECRET SERVICE, HIS
FAMILY, THEY ALL GET TESTED
REGULARLY AND FRANKLY I THINK
THEY SHOULD, HE’S A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE, FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT.
AS FOR THE MASKS, WELL, I’VE
BEEN SAYING THIS FOREVER.
PERSONALLY, I WAS AT THE
EPICENTER OF ALL OF THIS FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING, I DON’T HAVE
A PROBLEM WEARING MASKS.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE I LOVE GRANDMAS AND
GRANDPAS AND MOMS AND DADS AND
THEY ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE AND
I WOULDN’T WANT TO LIVE WITH
MYSELF IF I HAPPENED TO GET IT
AND PASS IT ON TO PEOPLE THAT
MAY POTENTIALLY DIE FROM THIS
AND ALSO I’M GOING TO BE VERY
SELFISH ABOUT IT, IF I HAVE TO
WEAR A MASK TO GO TO A BASEBALL
GAME OR AN OUTDOOR CONCERT OR A
FOOTBALL GAME IN THE NFL OR
COLLEGE AND THAT’S THE ONLY WAY
I CAN GET TO SEE THE GAME, IT
WOULD WORK.
BY THE WAY, I KNOW ONE LITTLE
MEASURE THAT WE HAVE
ANECDOTALLY, I’VE SAID IT SO
MANY TIMES ON THIS SHOW, ONCE,
TWICE A WEEK SO I WENT TO MY
LOCAL GROCERY STORE, I SAW THE
SAME PEOPLE, EVEN ONE OF THE
GUYS STOCKING THE SHELVES, I PUT
THEM ON MY RADIO SHOW.
SAME CASHIERS, I LIKE THE FAST
CHECK OUT MYSELF BUT I SAW THE
SAME PEOPLE AND THANK GOD, I
WOULD ASK EVERY WEEK, NO WOODY N
CONTRACTED TO BE A BECAUSE THEY
ALL WORE MASKS.
FOR ME, ANECDOTALLY, IT WORKS.
OUR SCIENTISTS ARE GOING TO GET
US THROUGH ALL OF THIS PROBABLY
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER BUT NOW
BIDEN, EVERYONE AROUND HIM IS
TESTED, HE’S USING THE MASK AS A
WEDGE ISSUE, A POLITICAL ISSUE
AND USING THAT AS A WAY TO
ATTACK PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BY THE WAY, HE WASN’T WEARING
HIS MASK WHEN HE WAS AT HIS
FIRST PRESS CONFERENCE IN 89
DAYS AND AGAIN, I WILL
REITERATE, EVERYONE AROUND THE
PRESIDENT MUST STAND IS TESTED,
SAME FOR JOE BIDEN SOAKED JOE’S
MASK-WEARING IS PURELY SYMBOLIC.
HE WAS AGAINST THE TRAVEL BAN,
THAT’S NOT SYMBOLIC.
THE ONE HE SAID WAS XENOPHOBIC
AND HYSTERICAL FEARMONGERING.
BUT THAT DECISION BY
DONALD TRUMP TEN DAYS AFTER THE
FIRST IDENTIFIED CASE IN
AMERICA, THAT SAVED PROBABLY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS FROM CONTRACTING THE
DISEASE AND TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
OTHERS FROM DYING AND FOR THE
LEFT EVERYTHING IS POLITICAL,
ESPECIALLY 126 DAYS BEFORE AN
ELECTION WHERE YOU WILL BE THE
ULTIMATE JURY.
IT ALWAYS IS SYMBOLISM OVER
SUBSTANCE.
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA DIDN’T
PRESS BIDEN ABOUT THE
POLITICIZING OF MASK-WEARING,
THEY DIDN’T ASK HIM ABOUT THE
VIOLENCE, THE LAWLESSNESS
ERUPTING IN AMERICA IS, THEY
DIDN’T ASK ABOUT THE MURDER
EPIDEMIC IN CHICAGO, THEY DIDN’T
ASK WHY DIDN’T HE AND BARACK,
WHY DID THEY IGNORE THEIR ENTIRE
EIGHT YEARS IN OFFICE ALL OF
THAT VIOLENCE, ALL OF THOSE
SHOOTINGS, ALL OF THAT DEATH,
ALL OF THOSE INNOCENT VICTIMS
FROM THE CITY OF CHICAGO, FOR
EIGHT YEARS WHILE THEY WERE IN
CHARGE, THEY DIDN’T ASK HIM
ABOUT THE VIOLENCE IN THE CHOP,
SUMMER OF LOVE ZONE, THEY DIDN’T
ASK ABOUT THE INSANE DEFUND THE
POLICE MOVEMENT THAT’S GOING ON
IN THE COUNTRY, THEY DIDN’T ASK
WEAK JOE ABOUT HIS ENTHUSIASTIC
ADORATION FOR THE FORMER
KLANSMAN ROBERT "KKK" BIRD.
THEY DIDN’T ASK ABOUT HIS WORDS
"THE RACIAL JUNGLE" OR
"PREDATORS IN OUR STREET"
SPEECH.
THEY DIDN’T ASK ABOUT HIS PAST
SUPPORT FOR SEGREGATIONISTS,
THEY DIDN’T ASK ABOUT HIS
INVOLVEMENT IN THE FLYNN PROBE,
THEY DIDN’T ASK WHY HE PROMOTED
THE LOGAN ACT TO TRY TO TRAP
DONALD TRUMP, THEY CERTAIN
DIDN’T ASKING WHY HE LIED ABOUT
IT, DIDN’T ASK WHY HIS SON, ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER GOT A
SWEETHEART $1.5 BILLION DEAL
WITH THE BANK OF CHINA, NO
EXPERIENCE THAT WE CAN FIND
RIGHT AFTER STEPPING OFF
AIR FORCE TO ON HIS TRIP TO ASIA
AND CHINA, THEY DIDN’T ASK ABOUT
BURISMA, THE LACK OF EXPERIENCE
WITH UKRAINE OR ENERGY AND THE
MILLIONS HE MADE THERE, THEY
DIDN’T ASK WHY HE’S SUPPORTING
THE NEW GREEN DEAL OR ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ ADVISING HIS
CAMPAIGN AND BY THE WAY I COULD
GO ON BUT WE ONLY HAVE AN HOUR.
PREDICTABLY THE MOB WERE GENTLE,
THEY WERE KIND, THEY GAVE HIM,
WELL, SPECIAL TREATMENT THAT HE
DOESN’T DESERVE.
THEY DIDN’T INTERRUPT HIM, THEY
DIDN’T SHOUT THEIR QUESTIONS,
THEY DIDN’T TRY TO GRANDSTAND,
THEY LOBBED ONE SOFTBALL
QUESTION AFTER ANOTHER AND FOR
REFERENCE, LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT
A SIDE-BY-SIDE COMPARISON
BETWEEN THE TREATMENT OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP VERSUS THE
TREATMENT OF THE EVER-WEEK
FORGETFUL JOE.
TAKE A LOOK A LOOK.
>> I WONDER WHERE DO YOU THINK
THE RATE STANDS AT THIS MOMENT,
WHAT KEEPS YOU UP AT NIGHT AS
YOU LOOK AHEAD AND CAN YOU
MAINTAIN THIS ADVANTAGE WITHOUT
CAMPAIGNING IN A TRADITIONALLY?
>> TODAY THE U.S. HAD A
MILESTONE OF 1 MILLION CASES OF
THE CORONAVIRUS.
BACK IN LATE FEBRUARY YOU
PREDICTED THAT THE NUMBER OF
CASES WILL GO DOWN TO ZERO, HOW
DO WE GET FROM YOUR PREDICTION
OF ZERO TO 1 MILLION?
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT TRUMP IS
GUILTY OF VIOLATING HIS OATH OF
OFFICE?
>> BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT WENT UP BY
.1%.
HOW IS THAT A VICTORY?
>> IF ELECTED, HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO GET AMERICANS ON THE SAME
PAGE?
>> Sean: SADLY BUT PREDICTABLE
AT THIS POINT AND GET THIS,
DURING THE FIRST PRESS OR IN 89
DAYS, THE EVER-FORGETFUL WEAK
JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY ADMITTED THAT
HE HAD A LIST OF PREFERRED
REPORTERS THAT HE WAS SUPPOSED
TO CALL ON.
WHAT’S INTERESTING TO ME ABOUT
THIS IS I’VE NEVER SEEN
DONALD TRUMP EVER DO THAT.
NEVER SEEN ANY PRESIDENT EVER DO
THIS OR PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE,
VERY INTERESTING, MAKES ME
THINK, MAKES ME PONDER, MAKES ME
WONDER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I’M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
IF YOU HAVE THEM.
THEY GAVE ME A LIST, HOW TO
RECOGNIZE.
WHO WAS I SUPPOSED TO GO TO
NEXT?
ANYBODY?
I’VE GOT TO MAKE SURE I GET TO
THE BLOOMINGTON NEWSPAPER HERE.
>> Sean: I DON’T KNOW IF
YOU’RE SUPPOSED TO SAY THAT OUT
LOUD, PROBABLY A BEST-KEPT
SECRET.
THE STAFF PROBABLY TOLD YOU BUT
YOU PROBABLY FORGOT.
LET ME STATE THE OBVIOUS, WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF A FEW OUTLETS,
FEW REPORTERS, RUSH, MARK,
LAURA INGRAHAM, A FEW OF US ON
FOX, THE MOB AND THE MEDIA IS
ALMOST ENTIRELY IN THE TANK FOR
JOE BIDEN, 9% ARE HACKS,
JOURNALISM HAS BEEN DEAD AND
BURIED SINCE 2007.
WE WERE PRETTY MUCH ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY THE ONLY ONES TO
TALK ABOUT BARACK OBAMA, WHO
FRANK MARSHALL DAVIS WAS, AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING AND ALL IN
ALL WE ASK THE TOUGH QUESTIONS
AND WHAT WAS BLACK LIBERATION
THEOLOGY FOR EXAMPLE?
FAKE JOURNALIST, NEW YORK TOILET
PAPER TIMES AND THE REST OF THEM
ARE BUSY ASKING OBAMA QUESTIONS
LIKE THIS, TAKE A LOOK.
>> DURING THESE FIRST 100 DAYS,
WHAT HAS SURPRISED YOU THE MOST
ABOUT THIS OFFICE, ENCHANTED YOU
THE MOST ABOUT SERVING IN THIS
OFFICE, HUMBLED YOU THE MOST AND
TROUBLED YOU THE MOST?
>> LET ME WRITE THIS DOWN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> SURPRISE.
>> TROUBLED?
>> WHAT WAS THE FIRST ONE?
SURPRISED.
TROUBLED.
>> ENCHANTED.
>> ENCHANTED?
>> AND HUMBLED.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHAT WAS THE LAST ONE?
>> HUMBLED.
>>>> Sean: ENCHANTING.
WE WILL DO THE JOB THEY WILL
NEVER DO, WE WILL THAT HONESTLY
THE PRESUMPTIVE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE THAT
THAT.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE NEXT 126
DAYS WILL BRING YOU EVERYTHING
YOU NEED TO KNOW ABOUT WHAT IS
AT STAKE FOR YOUR KIDS AND YOUR
GRANDKIDS IF, IN FACT, HE AND A
RADICAL EXTREME SOCIALIST EVER
TAKE POWER.
IT WON’T BE PRETTY.
I HAVE A BOOK COMING OUT IN 35
DAYS, "LIVE FREE OR DIE."
IN LATIN I PUT IN "LIVE FREE OR
AMERICA DIES."
THEY WANT TO TAKE US DOWN THE
FAILED ROAD OF SOCIALISM AND
THEIR AGENDA, IT WILL MAKE
AMERICA UNRECOGNIZABLE, THAT’S
ABOUT IT WILL BE AND THAT’S WHY
YOUR VOTE IS GOING TO A MATTER
ESPECIALLY IN FLORIDA, OHIO,
GEORGIA, NORTH CAROLINA,
PENNSYLVANIA, MICHIGAN,
WISCONSIN, MINNESOTA, ARIZONA,
NEW MEXICO, NEVADA,
NEW HAMPSHIRE AND MAINE’S SECOND
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
WE WILL LEAVE NO STONE UNTURNED,
EXPOSE EVERY SCANDAL, ASK EVERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION, WE WILL DO
THEIR JOB.
THAT IS OUR PLEDGE, THAT IS OUR
JOB TO YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE WERE PRETTY MUCH ALONE IN THE
DEEP STATE AS WELL, RIGHT THERE,